uh thanks again for the invite so um
today i'll be presenting um
a talk on language processing on quantum
hardware
with disco pai so it's joint work with
bob cook giovanni de fedice and
constantinos mission helicities
and we're all affiliated with the
quantum group in the computer science
department at oxford
and we're also working with cambridge
quantum computing
so yeah let's get started
so for an outline um today i'll be
trying i'll try to keep the slides short
and then
go to a demo so first i'll introduce
diagrams to string diagrams
from the point of view of geometry of
algebra and then
from the point of your data which is the
one that is going to interest us here
and then i'll explain
what we can do with diagrams uh
essentially we can apply functions to
them so that i'll explain what that
means
and i'll give two examples one is
natural language semantics
and the other is quantum circuit
evaluation
so then hopefully i'll get enough time
to show a nice demo
of discovery working in action on
some quantum natural language processing
experiments
so both simulations and real hardware
quantum hardware experiments and then if
at some time again i'll talk about
the future directions or feel free to
ask me more questions about that so
um let's get started so
what is a diagram so from the point of
view of geometry a
diagram is just a bunch of points and
lines on the plane
so on the left we got the cover of
kandinsky
pungton linear sufflacia so
where he describes how painting is all
made of points and lines on the plane
and on the right we got planar diagrams
and tensor algebra a seminal paper from
the 80s by joy on streets
where essentially they give a rigorous
definition
of a class of diagrams that are found
in a lot of different um
different sciences uh with a lot of
different applications the main one
being
the first one being physics so penrose
started drawing these diagrams and joel
street
were the one to first give them a formal
mathematical definition
so what is a diagram it's a bunch of a
bunch of points so
like this a b c and d and a bunch of
lines
um like this capital a capital b
and essentially um that's it so it's a
bunch of points and lines on the plane
the small caveat is that we consider
them with a
boundary so there's here left boundary
uh with abc
and right boundary so it means we can
paste diagrams together we can put them
side by side or one after the other
so why are string diagrams important
well because they capture precisely
monoido categories so
what is a monoido category essentially
it's
a collection of processes that you can
draw diagrams for
so what does that mean well essentially
the intuition is we've got
systems and processes between them so a
system we're going to represent as
a wire with an arrow going from here
left to right
so so t is a system and s is a system
and when we tensor them it means we're
just putting the wires side by side
so mathematically we're going to write s
tensor t
and diagrammatically we're just going to
draw one wire next to another
with the labels so
we've got an empty diagram which
corresponds
mathematically to the unit object of a
manual category and
essentially it means that if i have a
system and i put nothing next to it then
it's it doesn't change anything
so next we have a morphism so
morphisms they can be represented as
points
as we've seen in the previous slide they
can also
more commonly they're drawn as boxes so
these boxes are going to have a number
of wires coming in
here a1 to a n and a number of wires
coming out
from b1 to bn and that's it so that's
morphism it's what we call a box in
disco pi
so i'll explain what you can do with
those or what they mean but
the main thing that you can do with
these boxes is you can plug them
um one after the other so for example if
i have a process that goes from a to b
so s in this example and an s prime
going from b
to c then i can plug them one after the
other and i get
a diagram with two boxes from a to b
to c and if i have two diagrams i can
also put them side by side so
in this example it's going to be the
tensor product
mathematically it's going to be it's
going to correspond to the tensor
product of
s and t so now there's one equation
essentially that rules these diagrams is
that you can slide a box along
its wire so that's what the equation at
the bottom says
is if i do f and then i do g and
they have no wires in common then it's
the same as doing
g then doing f and
essentially that rule captures the fact
that if f has no side effect
then it f and g have no side effects
and they don't influence each other then
it doesn't matter which one
happens first so that's what we mean by
having two processes
in parallel so diagrams
are first the geometric object the
things that you draw on the plane and
then they also have an algebraic content
what that means is
you can describe these diagrams as
equations more precisely as equations
that describes
arrows in a minor category so anything
that you can build
out of essentially the empty diagram and
a bunch of lines that we call identities
and then tensor and composition
so there's a a lot of different
flavors of frame diagrams like are you
allowed to cross
wires or not are they like you can add a
lot of gadgets to your diagrams and
there's essentially a big zoo of
diagrams and
there's this really nice survey by
salinger
on the graphical languages of monodo
categories so
i'll refer to that for more technical
details
so here i'll try and be quick and i
won't spend
so much time introducing the
mathematical definitions
so let's go directly to the python
definition so
the starting point is an implementation
of string diagrams
so we've got a bunch of python classes
we've got a
class for objects so these are the
atomic wires the
single wires of our diagrams then a type
can be
multiple ones pasted together so x1 up
to xn will be
object and then
we've got a box so what is a box well a
box has a name and it has a domain and a
codomain which are types
so essentially that's the python
implementation for
what i've just drawn before a box which
takes any number of wires in
any number and leaves any number of
wires out
and it just got a name so the label in
the box
and so technically we need to define
what a layer is so that's just going to
be one slice of our diagram and what
that is
is a box in the middle and then a bunch
of wires to its left and to its right so
for example
here i have a layer with
a wire x on the left a box g in the
middle and nothing on the right
the layer after will be a box f in the
middle
nothing on the left and a wire on the
right and now what is the diagram or a
diagram is going to have a bunch of
is going to have a bunch of wires coming
in the domain
it has a bunch of wires going out the co
domain
then it has a list of boxes and a list
of offsets and offsets essentially tell
you how many
wires are to the left of each box so the
offset of g in this case will be
one the offset of f will be zero
and essentially under the hood if you
just give me boxes and offsets
this couple is going to calculate a list
of layers so you can also give that
as input but it's optional so let's just
look at the the syntax
and how you use it so you import
everything from this copy
then you create x y as a w a bunch of
types
now you can create boxes specifying
their input and output types so f goes
from x to y
g goes from z to w and
you can write any complicated expression
for a diagram using
this is the tensor product
and that's as close as we found in
python
and the double
uh greater or equal is the composition
so
that is kind of close enough so anything
that you can build
out of boxes identities composition
and tensor is a diagram if it type
checks
if you don't get any type error from
python then you build a valid diagram
you can draw it so
this diagram is going to correspond to
the to the figure on the right
and now you can use this copy as
essentially an algebra system
to check equations between different
diagrams
so check equations of monoidal
categories
so for example this diagram that i've
written you can also define it directly
instead of using the formula you can
just specify the domain co-domain boxes
and offsets
um and you can also check that um
essentially you can check that two
diagrams are equal if they have the same
normal form so that's just essentially
it takes a diagram and
moves boxes around so that you can check
that two diagrams are equal
so that's um useful but it's just
essentially abstract mathematics so how
do you make it uh concrete
well let's go to the next slide so what
can you do
with a diagram one you can apply a
functor to it so
the functor is going to be the
essentially the second data structure
discopy and
how you instantiate a functor you give
it a dictionary
for objects and a dictionary for arrows
so the dictionary is going to
send every basic object so every wire to
another object so it could be
a number of wires or it could be
something else so that's what factory or
r factory do
is essentially you can you can define
functors that
instead of just drawing diagrams do
computation so
the the main example that um
we've been working on is uh natural
language
uh processing uh essentially we start
from
this diagram on the left is um
representing the grammatical structure
of a sentence so here we've got alice
loves and bob
and we know that alice is the subject of
loves and bob is the object of love
and that gives us a sentence so you can
take this diagram and essentially
replace every triangle here with
a vector and
now computing the value of this diagram
essentially is going to replace
every wire by a vector space and every
box by
a linear map or a matrix and that means
that
you draw the diagram you replace every
box
every word by its meaning so a
vector for for nouns or a matrix for
verbs etc
and what you get as the application of
the functor is the meaning
of the sentence so i'll show an example
of that
just after and the the second example of
um
what you can do with discopay is you can
draw
any quantum circuit so here's an example
on the on the right of
the quantum circuit where we've got a
bunch of kits so
that means i'm preparing a qubit and
then we've got
we've got quantum gates like h which
takes a qubit and rotates it
and we've got the cx which takes two
qubits and entangle them
and then we also have scalars around and
we have
bras which essentially do measurements
and post selection so
if that doesn't make any sense to you um
it's i'll try i'll explain more of it
in the demo so essentially what
we've been doing with quantum natural
language processing is
we've been implementing this disco by
library that
can implement any monoido category and
now
the grammatical reductions of natural
language live
in a monoi locatory quantum circuits
live in another category
and what a functor can do is it can take
your sentence
and translate it into a quantum circuit
that computes
its meaning so essentially that's what
happens here on the left we've got a
we've got a sentence with a bunch of
words and
how they're connected together the
grammatical structure on the right
we've got a quantum circuit that is
going to compute the meaning of that
sentence so here the block on the top
would be the meaning of loves
and this kit zero is the meaning of
alice this get one is the meaning of bob
so
here's a bit of a trigger example and
essentially what happens with these cup
shape
wires so these bent wires is that in
quantum mechanics they will correspond
to
the bell effect so essentially what's
happening here is that
we're using quantum teleportation to
send the meaning of a noun to
its verb and essentially
using quantum teleportation where
computing
the meaning of sentences so
yeah i think that's why
for the slide so i'm not gonna explain
any more maths and i just
go to the go to the repo so
okay the link doesn't want to open up it
does
so here's the repo we just got to a
100 stars on github so we're really
happy and
we're still working on it so there's a
lot more features coming
and yeah it's got a bunch of
documentation
and there's a an archive paper on the
archive that explains the
both the maps and the code behind the
behind the
battery and well the most important
thing for us is going to be the
notebooks
so we have plenty of them
and so the one i'll be showing what
i would want to show is the qnlp
experiment
notebook where we actually do what i've
just said
on real quantum hardware
from idmq and well
that's probably not gonna work out in a
zoom meeting so
well i mean calling ibm q and waiting in
the
in the queue for um for for the quantum
machine
is probably going to take too long so
first i'll
go through the same experiment using a
simulator instead
so right so here's my notebook
so i'm going to import types and words
so what is a word essentially it's a box
that has a name like alice and a type
it's grammatical type so here noun
and for verb it's going to be a complex
type like it takes a noun on the left
it takes a noun on the right it gives
you a sentence so that's the idea
so you define your words you define your
basic types first
and now you have your vocabulary you can
ask this go by to look for grammatical
sentences
so alice is rich is a grammatical
sentence bob is rich he's one as well
alice loves alice alice loves bob
alice who is rich is rich not very
interesting but
that's grammatical as well so we'll just
brute force through
um the all the grammatical sentences
it's going to take a bit of time um and
so what are we going to do with these
sentences essentially we're going to use
these random or these brute force
sentences as a corpus
for our experiment so we're going to
take all of these sentences
and we're going to turn each of them
into a quantum circuit
this quantum circuit is going to have
parameters
um defining it so each word has a set of
parameters that define a
bit of circuit and when you want to get
the meaning of the sentence
you take the meanings of the words and
you plug them together
along the grammatical structure and that
gives you the circuit for the sentence
so every word comes with parameters and
that means we can use
essentially quantum machine learning to
learn those parameters so that
well so that we can capture the meaning
of sentences that comes from a corpus so
in
our case it's going to be a toy corpus
and
well the brute source is taking longer
than i was expecting
but that's okay i'm done okay so we've
got a lot of sentences here or 20
sentences i think
it's a really small corpus but it's
going to be enough
for our demo so let's draw one of them
so we've got this complicated diagram
with
alice who loves bob is rich and
the grammatical structure for it now
essentially we're gonna define this
complicated
circuit this bit of circuit which
prepares a special quantum state it's
called the ghz
states which is going to be the meaning
for the world who so there's
there's been a lot of literature on how
relative pronouns like who
can be modeled nicely on quantum
computers using this special state
and now i'm gonna define
a bunch of circuits so one um
for the verb is rich so for intransitive
verbs and one for the verb loves
so the verb loves essentially is going
to take two qubits in
and spit a scalar so the result of a
measurement out
whereas the verb is rich just takes one
noun and
gives a result so
okay so now essentially we've got two
dictionaries
objects uh it's going to send every type
of our grammar so here sentence and noun
to a number of qubits
so nouns are going to have one qubit
it's a third experiment
and sentences are going to have zero
qubits and what that means is
essentially a sentence
will correspond to a scalar so
a sentence will correspond to the
results of a measurement from
a quantum socket so that if
the results are close to one it's a true
sentence
if that goes to zero it's a false
sentence so
right um now we've got these two
dictionaries one sending um types to
number of qubits
the other sending words to bits of
circuits so alice gets sent to get zero
and bob gets them to get one loves to
this
complicated parameterized circuit well
complicated it's
essentially it's doing just one rotation
it's
kind of simple but now we've got these
two
dictionaries we can essentially build a
functor or more precisely a function
which takes parameters and constructs a
functor
and we can apply this functor to for
example alice who loves bob is rich
and we get this complicated circuit so
here we can spot the meaning for who and
over there is the meaning of alice and
that's the circuitry that you need
to glue the words together now
what can we do with this socket well we
can evaluate them so
essentially evaluating a circuit is
again applying a functor it takes a
qubit and it maps it to a vector space
so qubit corresponds to two-dimensional
vector space and it takes a gate and
maps it to a matrix
so for example yeah rotations along the
x-axis would be an example
so all right so we've got um we've got
our functor
now we're going to evaluate this functor
um on every sentence of the corpus we're
going to get a bunch of circuits
and for each circuit we're going to
evaluate it so that's what this
corpus does it takes the sentence
evaluates it
and computes the truth value so for each
sentence
we're going to have something that is
either close to 1 or close to
and here we are so the true sentences of
our corpus will be alice is rich
alice loves bob bob los ales etc and
here are the four sentences
now we're gonna use sk learn to split
the
corpus into training tests and training
set then testing set
let's standard machine learning now
we're going to use jax library from
google
which essentially allows us to compute
the gradient of any
python function which is very useful in
our case because we have this python
function which evaluates a quantum
circuit and it's kind of a complicated
function you don't want to write the
derivative yourself so
you ask jack to do it you you ask jax to
do it
also jax there's just in time
compilation so
it's very efficient for simulation or
the first time it takes
a long time and then it's going to be
very fast
so yeah it took it took 12 seconds to to
compile the
loss so essentially to apply a function
on every circuit for the first time
and here we're
we're computing the loss with respect to
the original
so with respect to the true parameters
so it's very close to zero
and now what we're going to do is
essentially we're going to
we're going to forget the true
parameters so the parameters that we
used to generate the compass
and start again learning them from
scratch so that's what
this cell does so we're just going to
start again from random parameters
and now we're just going to run
some vanilla gradient descent to
learn the function so essentially what
that means is we want to learn
parameters for loves and for is rich
so that we reproduce the original data
so we started from
some parameters param 0 and now we
forgot param 0 we start again from
random parameters
and at the end what we want is to
convert
back to the original thing so
yeah it can it it went pretty fast so
the first time you run it it
took 12 seconds now it's in microseconds
so that's pretty good now
is alex bob rich well according to
the parameters that we've learned yes
she is so
that's a small example of question
answering essentially we're taking a
question and we're
turning it into quantum circuit and
depending on the
result of the measurements we're gonna
say yes
or no so in our case it's binary but you
can make it
more complicated and now just to
finish with a beautiful picture um
we're just gonna just because it's a
classical simulation and because we can
we're just gonna
compute the whole landscape to just see
what it looks like
and here we are so
that's the landscape of the lost
function for amaro
depending on those two parameters for
loves and for is rich
and that's what it looks like so i i
think the main point of quantum machine
learning is that we get different kinds
of landscapes than the ones we get
from neural network or classical neural
network so
it's an example of
a landscape for quantum machine learning
experiment
um and it gets really hard as the
dimensions grow up so i'll just show the
same experiment just to wrap up
i'll show the same experiment but on
real quantum hardware this time and i
guess the
one thing i haven't mentioned yet is
that to run
our diagrams on quantum hardware we're
using
um the library from cqc that's called
tickets
it's a compiler and it takes essentially
the diagrams and it turns them into code
for kiskit so that's the library from
idn
so now we've got this kisket circuit and
we can essentially use ticket to do all
the job for us
to send these circuits on the quantum
hardware
we just have to wait in the queue and
show
what waiting in the queue looks like so
you just wait for the job status to go
to
success and you wait again and you shoot
a lot of
targets to get some
updates for your parameters until you
converge and
at the end after a long waiting time
what you get is that is alice who knows
rich
yes she is and i think
that's what i have to let go of the show
thank you
um i
uh so for the questions i guess
we don't have any questions in the chat
so i do have a question okay great
um i was wondering i mean um what's the
eventual goal
of doing it in this diagrammatic thing
what's the advantage doing nlp
diagrammatically
over overdoing it just with this let's
call it brute force deep learning gpt 3
type of thing you take a lot of data
you train a lot of weights you get some
results
you can perform really good on
question answering tasks for example
what's the benefit
um so i guess the benefit
for now is a hard to see because we're
only playing with toy mode so obviously
we're not trying to compete with gpt3
or anything like that and i guess the
main point is that
using these diagrams essentially we make
things easier for the
quantum hardware so
oh i was muted yeah sorry yeah
um when so yeah i was saying um those
diagrams
essentially get you closer to the
quantum hardware and
essentially they make the life easier
for the quantum hardware so
these trillions of parameters that
gp3 is going to use for example
essentially a lot of them are going to
be dedicated to learning grammar
and to learning how words connect to
each other
and here we're giving that to the
computer for free so
essentially that's going to save a lot
of computation that
the quantum machine doesn't have to do
and for now the quantum machines we have
are really bad so we can't really expect
them to do
trillions of parameters and also
i guess um it's also a step towards
explainable ai
so in a sense once you have these
diagrams it makes more sense why
your model gives this or that answer in
a sense that you can
essentially open the black box of your
neural network so that
it's easier to explain because now you
have these diagrams that show you how
the meanings connected to each other and
instead of having just a black box uh
transformer or whatever so um
yeah i guess it's a big topic i mean the
the future directions would be
to show that quantum hallway
has an advantage compared to classical
hardware and
so that's already been shown by google
but
to show that that's true not only for
the useless tasks that google
uh used for the experiment but for
useful stuff so
essentially quantum advantage for useful
problems would be the
the overall the long term goal
okay thank you so there is one question
from constantinops
i think he's your boss or is he a
colleague i guess
uh yeah he's a colleague yeah yeah i
think uh he can also
can you want to ask yourself constant
you know
yeah hi i just i just wanted alexis to
give some thoughts on
on on combining like
thoughts on on combining diagrammatic
formal methods like the ones you showed
with uh with uh ones that uh
that are mainly empirically driven like
deep learning
and brute force supported let's say
maybe not today but like
you know well i i think it's a big
question and we're probably not gonna
answer it completely in in five minutes
but um
i i guess a quick answer to the long
question would be
that um the so disco pi the
this and the core come from
distributional compositional so the
compositional stuff is all about these
diagrams that show how you compose wells
together
and the distributional power is what
comes inside of
the boxes for each world so that's what
the matrices
uh are for that's what the quantum
circuits do
so essentially the aim of these
diagrammatic methods
are in the long run to use all the power
of
distributional semantics which is
essentially what neural networks do they
learn from distribution
of worlds and how wells come in
sequences to
learn what is a likely sequence
uh or not or what is the answer to a
question
and they do that from a lot of data and
i i think
um for now we are only at the beginning
but the
the point i think the most important
direction is really this explainable ai
idea of not only we want these black
boxes that
can answer every question but we don't
know why we
want the machine to explain why it gave
this or that particular answer
and i think that's what the diagrams
would would help you
would help you achieve okay
there's a comment from your boss bob
i think it's is it a comment or is it a
bit of a
question um
yeah no there's another question from
michael paris
okay michael perez seems to have a
question now uh before that
uh michael would you excuse me there is
a question from luke jordan uh do you
want to unmute yourself and ask it or
you want us to read it sure this might
be a bit naive and somewhat general but
it just strikes me there's a lot here
that's
similar to um graphical methods
in things like causal machine learning
where it's again
and in fact graphs and diagrams i'm sure
there's a rigorous
distinction between them but they seem
quite similar and we're in a lot of work
causal machine learning is trying to
understand exactly that kind of
interrelationships in a way that seems
very similar
is there an overlap is that something a
huge overlap i mean um so bob has a
paper on using uh
these diagrams to do bayesian reasoning
and
i i know some people a lot of people
have started to apply these diagrams and
monolith categories to
bayesian reasoning to causal inference
to
um yeah so there's a big overlap and i i
can send some
some pointers to the literature if
you're if you're
cool that'd be great okay
and then there was another question from
uh space based on
you can use it to learn logical
relations get logic truth of your data
and uh yeah so that's uh
basically that's what we've been doing
before we implemented this stuff on
quantum hardware we
were treating it as a way to
essentially turn a question in natural
language to
a query for a database or equivalently
to a
logical formula and so yeah
this stuff works really well with logic
because category theory and logic go
really well together so i could send
some
some pointers for for that kind of stuff
as well
okay i think uh before we go with
michael's question again i think if
there are any other questions we can
take them first and
or else yeah michael i guess um
yeah you want to ask it or you want to
just sure
so um in your example you had to sort of
teach the system what the grammar of
each word
was for example the word loves you
defined it
as a specific type something that takes
it down from the left the noun from the
right
returns a sentence and um
wouldn't this be a problem or a
disadvantage in a sense
uh compared to gp like some general
purpose
uh natural language yeah well i guess
you ask the
the big question or the the main
question um
that sort of stands in front of us if we
want to apply this stuff to
real data and not only to our hand-drawn
diagrams
is how do we get from text which is what
usual machine learning
will take is input to diagrams and
that's a really
crucial step if you want to apply this
stuff in practice right so
if you want the model to be end to end
you can't assume that the
computer is going to guess the diagrams
so
i guess one answer is from like formal
language
theory is you can train
essentially you can train a model to
learn the grammar and you
there's a lot of work on grammar
induction so learning
the types for each world and learning um
how they connect so that's one answer
and it's of the traditional answer
people in formal language theory will
just use grammar induction first and
then a parser and
there's no machine learning involved
or the direction that essentially we
would want to take
is to essentially make this grammar
induction
the first layer of an end-to-end model
where
essentially a machine learning algorithm
would come to learn
how to draw these diagrams and learn
what are the types for the words
all from data so essentially there's a
lot of work showing that neural networks
and transformers and
recurrent neural networks convolutional
neural networks that they managed to
capture some grammatical
structure so there's people
experimenting with neural networks and
showing that they learn grammar
in the first layers and essentially
what we would want to do is to
make that more explicit in the sense
that
making the machine learn diagrams rather
than
just making it uh some implicit layer in
the middle of
the neural network um uh
i guess yeah that's a big question so um
but yeah we're definitely working on it
yeah thank you um seems like there are
no more questions or
if there are any questions people can
still
yeah we still have time sometime
okay if there are no questions then we
can take a break of eight minutes and
we can come back at eight with the
second presentation from proceed
and yeah
so meanwhile uh stay on and uh
we can take a break um
yeah thanks for the questions yeah
thanks alex
again thanks for giving a nice talk um
and um yeah would you also put up your
slides
somewhere uh yeah so that uh yeah
i shall yeah sure that would be great
so i'm just checking if i missed out any
questions or
i think yeah pretty much
okay
so are they anyone who wants to announce
anything or anything about like an
conference or something yeah you can
also do that
yeah from the from the participants
okay
so alexis i think i can ask a general
question
so like the quantum machine learning has
been now kind of
uh like there have been some use cases
where they've been applying some quantum
support vector machines and stuff
yeah to to real use cases and that was
uh
some people from ibm working with uh
yeah one from the
the computer science department yeah
so what stage is it quantum nlp is in
like are there any
like any small use cases for real
uh uh are they called like practical use
cases or anything
do you foresee anything practical no so
for now practical if you want to do
practical nlp you do gpt3
you train trillions but
i mean what's the state of qnlp there's
a workshop happening next week
and there was one happening last year
already and
for now that's pretty much what the
state of qnlp is
is we're organizing the first workshops
on the topic
and there's a few uh papers
on qnlp but uh using
essentially just doing the math for what
qnlp would look like
if we had big enough quantum computers
here what we're trying to do
is to make it happen on near-term
quantum computers
um but yeah for now there's a bunch of
algorithms that could apply if the
quantum computers
got big enough and there's a first proof
of concept of
doing something on a near term on a like
doing something on a computer from today
which is
really bad and noisy and all that
okay so if i is there anything
like an hybrid like a like a quantum
classical thing of
version for nlp too because from quantum
machine learnings it's bit off and
it's not purely quantum you can also run
on a classical computer but mostly like
a hybrid
one where you simulate it so um
here the hybrid part was happening
essentially the
so i i couldn't really go slowly over
the the
actual quantum experiment but what
happens is you have these quantum
circuits that you evaluate on
quantum hardware and then the results
for the measurements go back to
a classical computer that is going to
decide the updates for the parameters
so essentially it's always a hybrid
classical quantum group
the quantum machine gets executed and
then the classical machine decides what
to
execute next right so it's it's always
going to be
a hybrid or at least for now for now um
we're not going to have quantum
computers
alone right they will work on the cloud
with
a classical pipeline around it and
that's what
uh i think it was by torch they just
released a
quantum module where now you can write
your pipelines in by torch where
some bits of the pipeline are quantum uh
algorithms so yeah if on the outside it
doesn't matter
whether you're using a neural network or
a quantum machine um
okay thanks that's great uh you can also
share the link here for the next
uh the the the school you're talking
about for
the next week one on quantity oh yeah
the quantum week of fun yeah sure
and then i'll send my screen my slides
i'll send them over by email
okay
so michael is there anything we need to
announce
usually i tend to forget some stuff so
from the pi data side
um well not that i know
except for unless you have mentioned the
code of conduct that was sort of broken
in the beginning of the session
but oh yeah i mean it happens um
it was kind of exciting um
for those of you who didn't witness it
we had a couple of zoom
bombers yeah joining the meetup and
yelling some unintelligible
stuff um
so uh we probably learned from that for
the next time
yeah to set up a waiting room and
yeah it's like the people who join
yeah i think yeah but i mean it's also
difficult to distinguish right i mean
it's well you can put them in yeah to
see if they're normal
they're not we kick them out um
so apart from that i think um well
usually at the pipe data berlin we have
lightning talks
like informal lightning talks if there
are people who have
vacancies in their companies or a
project that they'd like to present
we gladly invite anyone to
step forward and announce a lightning
talk could be like
a two minute lightning talk or you just
talk about your recent project
or any type of thing that you would like
to announce
it's generally an option
outside of pandemic times um
right now it isn't quite an option
because
we are white to two people but still i
i welcome anyone to step forward and
announce anything like
vacancies in their departments or
um their company or if you're looking
for anyone to collaborate on an
open source project um yeah i think
that's also something
um in the past we had a lot of people
who collaborated on a lot of open source
projects
yep also disco bay is all open source so
yeah
collaborate uh for free yeah
cool that's great okay oh the cambridge
one okay
i think yeah i saw this yeah
okay i think we have all the people so i
guess
uh now we can start with the second talk
which is by proceeding
i think i spelt your name correctly i
guess yeah yeah
so you can go ahead with a very
interesting one on socially responsible
ai
so you can also do your introduction
like what do you do and
stuff right yeah
[Music]
okay
so i'm starting then okay good evening
everyone
so today um uh so first let me give a
brief introduction of myself i am
practicing i am a phd student in dublin
city university
and uh today i will be presenting our
work towards socially responsible ai
cognitive bias ever multi-objective
learning
this is a joint work with devastating
from ibm research dublin
so this work has been accepted in triple
ai 2020
so so there are a lot of factors
that can cause cognitive bias the
different factors
involved are memory social um social
structure
learning belief money politics
and depending on all these factors
different kind of bias can arise
so in our work we have specifically
focused on stereotyping bias
where the sources are like all the
different features that i described
earlier this memory social learning and
belief money and politics
so the objective for uh work is to
mitigate this stereotyping bias from
ai-based
classification models and so we want
a perfect balance between this fairness
and the accuracy of the model that's the
objective of this work
[Music]
so human society has historically
exhibited bars through gender and race
there are data and so now we use the
data driven deep learning models and
they
usually tend to pick up those bias from
the human generated content
and that's why we get biased predictions
there are examples like
uh terrorist prediction models which
they intend to
predict a brown skin colored person as
terrorist
similarly it has been shown in previous
work that suppose for the word embedding
the distance between the vectors like
vectors of the words like male and
programmer is lesser compared to the
distance between the word vectors for
female and programmers
for the emotion prediction system it has
been seen that
like a female gender is generally
associated with the emotions like fear
and anxiety
so um but this shouldn't be
the this shouldn't be acceptable and
there are a lot of examples in in terms
of search also
um so the first example that i am
showing here this is from google image
search
so if you search about the ceos
and google image search so here you can
see the top results that we got
so in general according to the
statistics 27
of the women are ceo i mean 27 percent
of the ceos are women
but as you can see from the picture the
11 of the
uh pictures are from the women's ceos so
this kind of imbalance is there
there is another example of query auto
completion
so if you search about um so this is uh
the example from a particular time
instant so when if you search about
scarlett johansson
who is a famous actress so the query
completion
examples that the google shows are like
in the body here and workouts we can say
that
the suggestion algorithm is prioritizing
this appearance over filmography
so what we can do to remove these bias
so first we need to identify the source
of
bias so in a simple feature based model
we can think of removing those features
that can
potentially cause bias in the model for
example new york police department
refrains from using the race of a person
to predict the risk of future crimes
but understanding exactly which feature
or or the combination of features can
cause these ethically incorrect
responses
that is not always easy and this
situation is far worse in case of
data-driven deep learning models
because we rely on the abstract
representation of data we do not
explicitly
give different features to the model for
example uh
what to wake and like there are a lot of
different models in these cases we can't
exactly identify
what is the exact what is the exact
feature which is causing bias in the
model
so uh so in this in our work we
basically proposed a model which can
remove bias in this kind of ai based
models
so to understand the uh bias mitigation
process first we need to understand that
first i will define the primary task so
primary task in our work is the
basic objective of the ai model
so in our case we have taken the
classification based model
so basically we work with the emotion
classification problem
so where the input is the embedded
vector representation of a sentence
and the output is the
emotion levels corresponding to those
sentences outputs are categorical
variables
for example in our case these are this
can be anxiety joy
and primary task is basically learning
the association between these input
vectors and the corresponding
levels so then we have formulated the
uh mathematically mathematically for try
to formulate the cognitive
bias so in our case uh to understand the
um understand these bars first we need
to understand the social identity
attributes
so these social identity attributes are
basically the set of attributes which
are
which can eventually lead to bias
for example gender race these are the
example of social identity attributes
and these are categorical variables so
they can have
like for example gender can be male and
female emotions can be fear
anger so a perf so the combination
of a subset of these identity attributes
and the uh output levels
can eventually cause bias in a model for
example for the emotional classification
task the association between the female
and the fear emotion
that can eventually lead to bias this is
basically
uh socially identity attributes and
based on these social identity
attributes we
label our bias variables so in our
research scope these bias variables are
basically binary variables which can be
one or zero
so ah with respect to each input
instance
in that training set we basically assign
one bias response variable
so the bias response variable is zero if
the corresponding social identity
attribute and the
output level the primary task output
level doesn't um i'm doesn't
come into the bias uh sensitive category
for example uh it's if it is about
male and fear then we do not assign that
but then we assign the bias response
variable as zero and it is one if it
belongs to the
um subset of categories which can even
potentially lead to bias for example
female and fear
so this is how for each input instance
we
assign this bias response variable
so after assigning this bias response
variable
then we have proposed this multitask
objective learning based
uh architecture to uh remove bias from
an existing model
so as you can see in this models first
in the initial layer is the
data vector thereby where you input
basically the data vectors
then that input layer is passed through
a shared layer
so this shared the objective of this
shared layer is to basically
transform the input data input data
vector space into a different space
where the bias will be less so
after passing through this shared layer
then we then we have the separate
architecture for the two different tasks
so one the first task is the primary
task learning status
um which is in our case the emotion
classification task
and the second task is the pseudo bias
response generation
task since we have the bias response
variable
corresponding to each input instance so
the
our the overall objective of this uh
function is the sum of both the primary
task objective learning function
and the biased response variables
variable function
so this is the the overall objective
function that i have shown here
the first one the where we have shown
this p of y given x theta p
theta s that is basically the primary
task learning function
and the second one so again for the bias
we can have
a model can have bias with respect to
different kind of social identity
attributes
can can can have the gender bias trace
path
so for each different type of social
identity attribute basically for each
different type of bias we define
separate bias response variable
so so for each bias response variable we
have
separate bias response generation task
so which is basically this p
y i b given x now as you can see
that in the overall objective function
we are basically trying to
minimize the primary task objective
function and we are basically trying to
maximize the bias response variable
generation objective generating
objective function the reason is that we
want to
d learn the bias response generation
function
because we do not want the association
between the kind of
like for example in our case between the
fear and female
so basically we want to relearn that
that's why we are maximizing this bias
response by using this minus sign
and we are basically minimizing the
primary task objective function
so this is an example with simulated
data
like what is the effect of applying our
bias
bias mitigation architecture so
in this simulated data we have basically
two classes as you can see the
colors of the um these points determines
the level corresponding to those points
and the blue blue blue solid line
basically shows the
uh boundary of the classifier in the
left hand side picture this
uh the the blue classifier is the
classifier where we didn't apply any
kind of bias mitigation architecture
and in the right hand side uh picture
the
blue line shows basically the boundary
of the um
classifier after applying the device in
architecture so
and this particular data has simulated
data has two dimensions only
x1 and x2 and the data set has basically
bias with respect to x2
so as you can see that compared to the
left hand side picture
in the right hand side picture maybe the
accuracy has reduced
but the bias is less i mean here you
cannot directly say
what you can say from the left hand side
picture that if a particular point has
h2 value less than 2 then always
it gets the red level but that
particular
uh conclusion you can't draw from the
right hand side one
so that's how the bias gets reduced
maybe at the
cost of accuracy but the bias gets
reduced
so now i will talk about the results
that we got with the real data set
real-life data set
so we use this equity evaluation corpus
which was the emotion classification
data set
so with corresponding to e and so this
was a balanced data set so
there were gender and race annotations
corresponding to each sentence
levels and regarding gender they had
annotations for male and female and
regarding race they had annotations for
african american and caucasian and for
each different type of social identity
attributes for example male
female or caucasian or african
ammunition african american as you can
see
that they had equal number of examples
that's what i said that
it was a balanced data set and the
emotional levels corresponding to its
sentences were
fear anger joy sadness and neutral
so there were a sentence which didn't
have any kind of
emotions annotated with that okay so we
used basically three different versions
of this data set so the first one was
the balanced data set this is the
original data set
and we also created uh some biased
dataset from this
from this balanced dataset the reason
was we wanted to see
the effect of balancing dataset in the
biasing
whether we can actually completely
remove bias
by using by supplying balanced dataset
so we have
created um two different versions of
bios dataset that was ss1 and ss2 in ss1
we have more number of female and fear
examples and mail and
anger examples compared to male and fear
and female and anger
and similarly in aces two we have more
examples of
more training examples of caucasian and
fear compared to african dominican and
fear
so these are the different approaches uh
we investigated
so the first category of approaches were
the bias agnostic approaches where we
basically didn't apply any kind of
debian technique
in the classifier model and we also used
this bias
agnostic l2 approach where we basically
added the regularization
with the standard class classifier and
just wanted to see that adding
regularizer
adding regularizer can remove the bias
or not
then we used this bias agnostic gender
feature approach where we basically
gave gender as an explicit input feature
to the
to the model to check that whether that
can remove bias or not similarly we also
tried to import rays as a spare
particular inputs feature
uh to the model and we also applied
debuss toward embedding so there are
standard techniques of uh rebirthing
whatevering so you are
we use debug stored embedding to check
whether using device orbiting
what emitting can remove bias from the
classifier model or not
so how we can remember basically
evaluate the effectiveness of a debian
approach so we proposed a metric called
fairness for our
uh for our um proposed approach and
we also and then using basically the
eventual objective
of a model should to should be to have
both accuracy and fairness and higher so
we also proposed a
combined app which is called we call the
karma which is basically the harmonic
mean of this
accuracy and fairness so how did we
exactly measure the fairness
so to measure the fairness we basically
measure the posteriors with respect to
different emotion categories
and different social identity identity
attributes
for example if we want to measure the
fairness with respect to the feature
with respect to the emotion fear and the
social identity attribute gender
then what we mean corresponding to
zender we know that there are two
different categories that is male and
female
so we measured that what is the
posterior of a person being
male even the gender is um
[Music]
given the gender is fear and similarly
we also measured what is the probability
that a person being female
given the gender is fear now basically
the fairness is basically the
multiplication of these
two posteriors so from the computation
as you can see that
fairness will be higher when
these posteriors will be uniform with
respect to the different categories for
example for male and female
if both of them are 0.5 and 1 5 then
fairness will achieve the maximum value
so yeah that's how we measure the
fairness and then this karma value
so this is the result that we got
so from this result the interesting
observations are that from
bias tag the first category of
approaches are the biased agnostic
approaches
so as you can see that from
using balanced data set obviously um
reduces the bias present present in the
model compared to the
using the bias dataset but it doesn't
completely removes bias from it
so that is the first observation the
second observation is that
using gender and race as explicit
feature doesn't help to remove bias from
a model
similarly we have also seen that using
debias toward embedding
didn't help to remove bias from the more
classification model
and and there is a recent paper in
knuckle 2017
so that also shows that the debugged
automating technique doesn't
um help to mitigate bias from the
downstream task
they may remove bias from the vector
space but eventually
uh the bias gets carried into the
downstream task
so the so our observation is basically
consistent with that paper
and then third comes our approach where
we try
to remove bias with the bias or a gender
approach by
race approach and the biases joint so in
the joint
method basically we try to remove the
bias gender and race past simultaneously
so as you can see that in our proposed
approaches
the fairness value has increased
compared to the
um compared to the debussed automating
approach and the bias agnostic
approaches
so yeah that's the main and the um
effect of using i mean the utility of
using the joint approach is that you
don't need to train your model
two times you can remove all the wires
simultaneously
yes that is the utility of this joint
approach so that's the main takeaway
from this
result yeah so in this work we tried to
remove
bias from a model where we had uh idea
about
the annotations where we had the idea
about the categories with respect to
which the model has bias
and we also have the annotations
corresponding annotations for the
data for the training data set but in
future
uh we'd like to export techniques where
we do not have uh annotations for the
whole data
or we have some partial annotations and
we will try to use that
to remove bias from the whole model so
yeah
that's um all so yeah
do you have any questions wow that was
quite quick
so yeah i think uh people can start
asking questions i think we have
time for more than a couple of questions
so
so
so if that note
oh wow um i think if there are no
questions
michael do you want to uh add something
you
i'm not as familiar with the topic to be
honest
but i i like the idea of uh i mean
in my work i have like a very similar
problem but not necessarily in this um
this domain but the general deep biasing
domain i mean it is really interesting
and
i am also working on a couple of methods
to devise my data set
um but from like
just because i'm not completely aware of
the data set that you've been using it's
very difficult i mean you will probably
work
okay if you're not really yeah
i mean i remember actually so project
are you aware of this ibm fairness tool
like the
uh that i have this aif uh
so is it your studies are also part of
that uh
no no okay because i remember like one
of my
uh like he's also part of the pi data
one so he actually worked on it
at some point so they
they would not be devised the data but
they would have metrics in such a way
that you can always uh measure the
fairness
yeah you can always have a
fairness measurement and you know try to
actually maximize it
so it's it's quite similar to the one so
yeah
but that was a long time ago so yeah and
i'm not aware of all the details here
but anyway thanks for the talk uh we'll
just also still wait for people
if they want to ask anything related to
it
so i think everyone can mute
a new themselves yeah so
so please if you want to have any ask
any question or even any comment yeah
please go ahead
[Music]
um
okay
that's
okay uh so your work will also uh
so your talk will also be available as
slides somewhere like uh or you can also
send us
yeah okay that would be great yeah so is
it also on github like uh
if someone wants to try it out uh like
yeah yeah there is a github link so i
will send both
okay yeah i can you can post the github
link on meetup
as a comment i think that would be
easier
and others yeah and if your talk is also
on github then you can also post that
link there
i will send you yeah sure
we usually have a github where we keep
all the pdfs of the talks
it hasn't been updated for some time so
we need to do that
again yeah yes
okay so anyone from the audience any
comments or anything
they want to okay yeah devices you can
go ahead with the question
one second
oh sorry yeah now i think you can unmute
yourself
oh hi yeah yeah uh since we've got time
for questions
and since i'm called her so i maybe i'm
not the best person to ask this question
but
you know since we have got time so maybe
we can go ahead yeah
uh we can discuss uh we have time for a
discussion
so uh one of the things that maybe
whatever that could be that i wrote down
is like
no what what kind of you know how how do
we plan to extend this work in future
because you talked about the
unsupervised approaches and the
semi-supervised approaches
how exactly you know you plan to do it
so that's question one
and the second question is you know we
have basically
addressed the classification task here
but there are some other tasks in
machine learning as well you know
regression tasks or i don't know some
some other
tasks like sequence leveling for natural
language processing
so how do you envision that you know
firstly you know
does it make sense to compute or do you
or to use the same metrics that you
already had used in your work
do those metrics extend easily to the
other types of tasks
if not then you know what kind of bias
quantification could you achieve for
those tasks
and how might you mitigate uh
biases for those tasks okay so there are
a lot of questions
when you have questions sorry about that
yeah so for the first question
i think regarding the problem that we
can't have annotations
for the like in real life scenario in
most of the cases we can't have
annotations for the
uh whole data set so one uh way
can be to design uh another oracle which
can
kind of predict uh the this social
identity attributes
using those like few annotations what we
have
then once we have that kind of oracle
then we can use that
to um to apply in ours in our
world like in the kind of architecture
that we have proposed because we need to
generate in any how the biased response
variables
so yeah that is one thing i i can think
of now
to apply where we do not have any
annotations
and regarding the second questions
like well since we have done with the
classification task but what will be for
the task
so obviously i think that um for the
other kind of tasks like regression and
sequence labeling
we can't essentially use the fairness
metric that we have used
somehow um so we need to somehow
quantify if we can quantify the
output and then um
basically we can categorize the output
the continuous output
into different levels and based on that
based on that we measure the posteriors
then we can use something like fairness
over there so basically we have to first
quantify the output the continuous
output level and based on that we need
to measure the
uh posteriors in our case that's what i
think
yeah so maybe maybe for regression it's
quite simple because they could trade
regression as
uh you could easily transform regulation
problem into classification one by
quantization so i guess enough
regression will be quite similar
but sequence classification is quite a
different
kind of problem right so where you
assign label to each
token in a sentence so you have to
identify spans of text let's say for
example open domain question answering
or i don't know
an implementation recognition
where you know you don't associate a
particular label to an instance
but you set a label to a particular
token or the particular word
so how how in that case could bias be
computed
or mitigated i mean i don't want to
answer but maybe some ideas in that
direction could be helpful
yes for sequence labeling also uh yes we
are predicting the sequence level but
they are also we have a fixed set of
output classes based on that
we are predicting the next uh next
sequence level so uh that's how
you can map that into a classification
problem i guess
because since you have a fixed number of
possible outputs
and obviously a sequence uh labeling
task basically
predicts the probability that what what
will be the
i mean most likely next sequence
so there also have a fix so the the each
output dimension can be thought of as
the different classes
okay thanks
are there any more questions or comments
okay seems like
not many questions uh
if so then yeah uh thanks again for the
talk nice talk presentation
approach and uh yeah
so i can actually make an announcement
about an
event which is happening it's called pi
data global
it's now an completely online conference
which involves all phi data from
from all all over the world so they are
pre
uh like more than 100 meetups
chapters local chapters around the world
so this is the one
so i think the cfp is already over
but the program is out but there are
also some
open sessions where you can you can find
collaborators to work on a project and
stuff like that
so yeah i ask everyone to check out
and
um and other than that
um yeah thanks a lot for everyone to
join uh i mean we can hang out for some
more time
because the talks are finished quite
early so
we still have some time to hang out and
if people want to announce or say
anything or
make any suggestions or anything
would be great
michael if you have anything else to say
you can also go ahead
seems like michael is
okay
um
okay so um
[Music]
anyone wants to start a discussion or
anything uh of that
kind
okay so since you since i'm new to this
so maybe
i could actually ask a few questions but
how often do you meet
so the meetup is actually every month so
we do it on the third week
third wednesday of every month that's
the idea so it's been quite regular for
like almost like four to five years
before that it was a bit
uh yeah um so it's been quite i mean
so we have regular meetups every month
and we also usually have an annual
conference every year
and so usually it would be around july
or
sometimes in august or sometimes in may
depending on the availability
but this year due to pandemic we
actually had to kind of
postpone the conference or kind of
cancel it and
do it for the next year
so we love last year we did the
conference it was a joint conference
with pycon d it's the largest python
conference in germany from the it's from
the
german python software band like the
software organization
and everything is actually they're all
open source are ngo non-profit
organizations
so yeah so none of these so this money
which is collected from all the
conferences and all the events goes to
uh projects which num focus supports
so okay so that's the idea
and unfortunately this year yeah we have
to cancel the conference and
hopefully we'll have it next year
and the plan is to have a joint
conference again
because pycon is also hosting the
conference in berlin
so we would have a joint conference uh
sometime we still haven't figured out
the dates yet
uh but we are planning about it yeah so
and uh apart from meetups there are also
some special events sometimes
like uh there are some people in berlin
who are like maintainers or
uh main core developers of uh
data science projects like psychic learn
and
other other ones like
spacey is also based in berlin so
sometimes they also we
also try to make these special events
which are focused on
open source developments
so yeah okay that's good
that's good
so so if i'm so you
uh you you're also a phd student or
you're done with your phds
and i'm there a long time ago okay i'm
sorry yeah then yeah
okay i graduated without in 2013.
okay oh that's a long time yeah so
projector you're a phd student right
yeah i'm finally a phd student okay
alexis you are yeah i mean if i
understand you you're not finished yet
right uh
no i'm uh right in the middle of the phd
okay
yeah yeah i think uh yeah that's
and
so yeah
um anyone wants to ask anything about
the pi data stuff also yeah
i can answer that yes so you said that
you know you have
regular call for papers you know every
year for the conference
yeah yeah exactly yeah the cfpb
so what is the main focus area of the
conference then uh
to a large extent it's very uh
broad so anything under the data science
under the sun of data science like more
but a lot of
times we have more focus on nlp
machine learning and deployment has been
a growing area
and also there are also python
programmers
like python libraries like a lot of
people talk about their new libraries
they have
built both for pyth uh data science use
cases or even in general
uh last year we because we combined it
with pycon we had so much of software
engineering side
also uh devops was also a big thing unit
test
testing and people also
talk about a bit about iot
and data science combined
and graph data science is something
which we did not have
extensively a lot of talks but
we had some topics related to it
this is something which is also like an
emerging
area yeah topic now right yeah yeah like
there is some i think there was a talk
on graph convolutional neural networks
but apart from that not much
okay and uh yeah there was
and also diversity in data science is
also something uh
which people uh like a lot of
people are interested in especially in
berlin
and also data science for social good is
also a big thing
so these are also the other topics
which are which are also part of the
conference but in general it's a very
broad
areas and um because it's
it's spanned over like four uh three to
four days so
yeah there's like plenty of room for
talks and uh
there are also a lot of uh short talks
lightning talks
and then there are tutorials so
okay yep
okay so
if there are no comments or anything for
a discussion
i think we can
we can end the session and thanks
everyone for joining and uh
um and special thanks to alexis and
pracheta for the talks again
and uh yeah we continue to have you
on on the meetup hopefully we will we
might have a
physical meet up soon yeah i hope so i
mean
thanks again for the organization and
everything yeah
i was kind of sad i couldn't come to
berlin yeah i remember you did
mention that yeah that
yeah so
yeah and thanks again and maybe we can
see again in the next month so
yeah this meetup is all uh is every
month and we do it on a
third wednesday of every month so
hopefully
to see you oh can you also let me know
once you you get the recording up
yeah sure yeah we we would first send it
to you both
and uh okay like uh take a view and then
yeah then upload it to the youtube
channel
yeah beautiful yeah great
so yeah thank you everyone and then
have a nice week evening and yeah
yeah ciao thank you ciao cheers thank
you
you